المنتخب التونسي تناسى نتيجه اول مباراتين
ضمن المجموعه الخامسه نسور قرطاج سيرفعون
شعار الفوز امام جنوب افريقيا لتامين
التاهل كوصيف للمجموعه او قطع بطاقه
العبور ضمن افضل اربعه منتخبات تحتل
الموقع الثالث في المجموعات الست بالدور
الاول للمسابقه ورغم تعقد وضعيه المنتخب
التونسي ظهر المدرب جلال القدري واثقا من
قدرات فريقه في التاهل تغييرات يعطي اكثر
انتعاش يعطي اكثر حلول للمدرب ولل
المجموعه لكن تعرف مباراه مصريه اهم شيء
بالنسبه لنحن صحيح الجانب البدني مهم
والانتعاش مهمه جدا لكن زاد ثم توازن تاع
الفريق توازن تاع المجموعه
التكامل اما جنوب افريقيا فتحتاج لنقطه
التعادل لبلوغ الدور التالي من المسابقه
القاريه لكن المدرب هوجو بروس اكد ان
الفريق قادر على تحقيق نتيجه
ايجابيه اشعر ببعض القلق لان المنافس حصل
على يوم راحه اضافي لكن الفوز في المباراه
السابقه يمنحنا دفعه معنويه وطاقه ايجابيه
لنحقق ما نطمح
اليه تواجه المنتخبان ست مرات حيث فازت
تونس بثلاث مباريات مقابل ثلاث
هزائم
ن